hi I'm Erik Bosse in the story of
adventures in game and of interest
infinity war featured a number of
deleted scenes that proved that when he
wanted to applaud about a Jack purple
space Conqueror collecting rainbow gems
to snap half of everyone in a dust and a
group of freaks using an inconsistent
time travel logic to reverse it you only
whittle your plot down to that by
starting with even crazier darker
unfilmable crap but you know the kind of
crap that lives on as fascinating
cutting room floor footnotes that
fulfills the fanfiction cravings of the
dreamers recently at Comic Con the
screenwriters of infinity war and
endgame Christopher Markus Stephen
McFeely spoke at what I considered one
of the most interesting and revelatory
panels of the whole conference opening
up about things like an alternate ending
where Thanos decap cap go watch that
video and the deleted scene that I'm
gonna talk about here
the mysterious planned but removed cameo
by The Living Tribunal and a haunting
Thanos trial sequence that would echo in
the nightmares of millions I'm gonna
break down what we learned and more the
warning in case I spoil the version of
these movies that's in your head or if
you've been saving the transcript of
this Markus and McFeely panel to
experience it in your own time your
weirdo okay last year after the release
of Avengers infinity war the filmmakers
hinted that there was actually going to
be a cameo from the Living Tribunal in
the movie during the battle against
Thanos on Titan now they didn't go into
further detail but the Living Tribunal
is the ultimate judge of the Marvel
multiverse it's got a giant naked golden
body and four-sided head that pivots
pivots its first three faces represent
equity vengeance and necessity and the
fourth is a void with the tribunal
claiming that the cosmic entity of the
stranger once existed as part of it yeah
[ __ ] you know a second ago there was
some really weird porn on that fourth
face it was a void it was a void anyway
The Living Tribunal is mostly associated
with the Doctor Strange comics but the
entity makes a key appearance in the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline that
Infinity Ward and game were adapted from
after Thanos snaps and breaks everything
the other cosmic entities like Galactus
appeal to the Living Tribunal to render
judgment on tanis's crimes and the
Living Tribunal ultimately decrees that
Thanos did nothing wrong that's right
one of those its verdict is that Thanos
is conquest of the infinity gems and his
actions adhered to the laws of nature
and survival of the fittest and
therefore Thanos is not guilty but
according to the infinity war an endgame
screen
writers there Living Tribunal scene was
going to go down quite differently and
so we stuck the Living Tribunal as
Thanos and Doctor Strange came to blows
Doctor Strange blue houses mined and
sent him through the center through the
mindscape so they're referring to the
battle on Titan infinity war when Thanos
and dr. strange engaged in their wizard
duel and the final cut of the movie
their duel is a volley of cool moves a
mirror dimension attack turning into a
black hole attack turning into
butterflies you remember it was awesome
but concept art from the film suggested
that this battle was going to be way
Trippier strange was as the writers
confirmed going to tap-dance this
warhead and blast him through the
multiverse just as the ancient one had
done to him and come our Taj this battle
was going to be insane but the two of
them continuing to duke it out on a
variety of interdimensional acid trip
surfaces but as the writers continue to
explain this trip was originally going
to go to much darker depths it was that
he's sort of zipping through the
universe being presented with all his
many many many many crimes right and so
bodies are being thrown at him he lands
and things turn into bodies like hands
are grasping at him it's just really
kind of grim and at the end he gets
dumped in front of the Living Tribunal
who judges him guilty guilty so think
about this one by one all of the a
Knossos victims were going to present
themselves as witnesses at his trial
kind of like a survival final Tribal
Council
we're the finale of Seinfeld but here
we're talking millions of victims Gamora
Loki Heimdall half des Guardians half of
Gamora stupid zo Bereans assuming
millions ons and are also Thor's pride
all of these victims rising from the
grave to pull Thanos deeper you think
about a strange might have been pulling
inspiration from his own multiverse trip
where millions of hands sprouted all
around him and pulled him down feeling
so good but really reflecting Strange's
naive fixation with mending his broken
hands here the hands would also probably
serve as metaphors birthday knows his
victims this also would probably have
looked a bit similar to the priori and
Ken Tatem moment in Harry Potter in
which Voldemort's past victims were
reincarnated as shadows to haunt him
during that wizard duel but it's
interesting that these screen
writers would have the Living Tribunal
judge Thanos as guilty when in the
comics he's found not guilty a not
guilty verdict would resulted an
interesting twist as a dozen comics
Vanus would be released from strangest
mindscape spell and strange would fail
and who would force him to fall back on
his final contingency plan but since
they intended for the Living Tribunal
finding him guilty it forces me to
wonder whether this Living Tribunal in
this deleted sequence was legit because
if Thanos was found guilty wouldn't that
just be the end of the story unless the
sentence was like a couple weeks of
community service picking up trash hunks
a car perhaps strange his spell was just
a projection of a trial a projection of
the Living Tribunal designed by strange
just to weaken Thanos this would be
similar to the illusion montage of
Mysterio that we just saw in spider-man
far from home in which the illusionist
terrorized his combatant with the
haunting vigils and memories of the
deceased in that case Tony Stark and the
other fallen Avengers from endgame in
both far from home and an infinity war
the recipient of this mine was
technically the hero of that story but
whatever this was the screenwriters
explained why they removed this sequence
from Infinity Ward when you introduced
the idea of the Living Tribunal my
grandmother would understand that well
it's also that guy exists yeah so it
came down to a matter of audience
alienation in stakes like a giant
multi-faced God judge is a pretty nuts
thing to throw at the audience but yeah
it's also a big leap to establish a
universal judge that any character could
just appeal to or like prey to to
intervene in whatever battle they were
engaged in it takes the pressure off the
Avengers in Thanos to settle this
conflict themselves it's always better
and more interesting if they settle it I
mean hopefully one day the MCU will go
because comics enough that audiences
will accept the existence of higher
powers that can intervene and deus ex
machina kind of ways kind of like
grandparents yelling down to the
basement i don't care if he broke your
nebula toy he's your brother now give
Ahmad yeah in my fantasies this one
above all is Stanley and you always will
be do you think this Thanos trial and
living tribunal cameo should have been
kept in infinity war so they had moved
it over
in game should they have still shot it
and rendered all the effects to
perfection just so that we could see it
in like a blu-ray deleted scene yes
right yes comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram twitter
at da vas and subscribe to the new rock
stars to break down theories about
everything marvel thank you for joining
me and let's all think about what the
living tribunals genitalia would look
like would it be four sides would it be
anything who knows
[Music]